this was the moment of arrest
jimmy ly put into an unmarked police van
outside his home in hong kong
then driven away
raided the publisher's office late in
the morning
he was then later brought to the offices
of his media company
next media the paper itself released
these pictures
mr lie being escorted around their
office by police officers
police said they were looking for
evidence but did not specify
what exactly the 71 year old jimmy ly
is among several arrested in a police
operation focused on his group of media
outlets
including the popular tabloid apple
daily
in a statement police said seven people
have been detained on suspicion of fraud
and colluding with foreign forces part
of the new security law
this morning around 9 45 together with
our colleagues from the criminal
investigation department
and military staff we got a warrant to
conduct an operation
to search for evidence our operation so
far smooth and we hope to finish soon
and not to disturb the operation of the
media
it is not the first time jimmy ly has
been arrested
china's state media has portrayed him as
a traitor and accused him of being one
of the masterminds behind the many
recent protests
in the city he is a well-known and
outspoken pro-democracy figure in hong
kong
who regularly criticize china's
authoritarian rule
many here in hong kong seem as an
unlikely hero
i don't think the police should be doing
this after all this is a media
organization
hong kong claims to have freedom of the
press so i don't think they should be
raiding the media's premises
the self-made billionaire and media
owner is the only high-profile business
person
who so far has been willing to openly
criticize beijing
the arrests come only days after the u.s
government announced sanctions on hong
kong and mainland chinese officials
it's a clear signal that china is
determined to enforce
the new security law despite growing
international pressure
well joining me now from london is
nathan law the chairman of
hong kong's democristo party he faces
similar
charges in hong kong and is threatened
with arrest if he
returns nathan what do you make of jimmy
lizarest
well this is definitely a classic signal
from the communist party saying that um
they would arbitrarily and are basically
using
uh the the the national security law to
prosecute any political attackers that
they don't like
so uh jim eli has been very vocal in
criticizing the
chinese government and protecting hong
kong people's freedom so that would
set up a case and to threaten the others
to be silent
well jimmy jimmy you say has been very
very vocal you also have been part of
these
uh protests is he as beijing claims the
mastermind behind this
the protest well of course of course not
um the way beijing portrayed that is to
frame these very prominent for this
mattress to take full responsibility
for all the um well upheaval
for the past year but actually this is a
leaderless movement um
people are acting on their behalf and
really devote themselves into the
movement with their own capacity
so um i don't think that is the reality
they just wanted
to cook up cases to prosecute prominent
activities
so you say the movement is a leaderless
one but how
is this high-profile arrest going to
affect the pro-democracy movement
well it would definitely create chilling
effects which means that um
even though like you are not a
so-called colluding with foreign forces
you are acting on your own
willingness but beijing could definitely
traumatic cases on you
and they will scare off of people who
still wanted to voice out in hong kong
so that is
beijing's agenda and i urge the public
not to be scared of
really giving out your voice are you
yourself i mean you're in exile if you
will in london right now are you
yourself scared
well of course we understand how far
reaching china's rich could be
and even though we are kind of scared
but
it's our choice to um adopt what action
to cope with it
my actions would be speaking louder and
louder to be
able to talk hong kong people's demands
and their genuine thoughts
overseas in order to get more
international attention and support
nathan are you going back to hong kong
anytime soon
well according to the state media i am
a wanted uh fugitive so uh it is
unlikely that i
am able to go back to hong kong but if i
do in the future
then it will be hong kong becomes a
democracy and free play
nathan law thank you very much
i know the law has already left hong
kong and many others are planning to do
the same the
number of residents leaving is at its
highest in seven years according to
official figures
fears that the territories freedoms are
being eroded have forced people
to consider their options gary
and his fiancee have just a few more
months to enjoy their life in hong kong
before they say goodbye to their
hometown and emigrate to australia
when gary filed the application five
years ago
leaving was only a backup plan since
then
hong kong has been through massive
social and political upheaval
but it was the unprecedented
anti-government protest last year
that finally pushed him over the edge
this isn't the hong kong i grew up with
anymore freedom has been restricted
hong kong will soon be no different from
the rest of china
i feel even more unsafe under the new
national security law
we've lost hope here so we have to find
it elsewhere
to fight or to flee that's a tough
question
for many hong kongers like gary starting
a life abroad will likely be a rocky
path
even in his job as an engineer gary and
his fiancee
who does not want to be interviewed
because she fears for her job here
are prepared to start from scratch it's
a price
they're willing to pay in exchange for
liberty
it's tough to abandon our well-paid jobs
friends
everything we've established here where
we were born and raised
we did struggle to make this decision
but around a third of my friends are
also considering
leaving or at least sending their
children abroad
factors show that the number of hong
kong residents living
is at its highest in seven years around
30 000 people left in 2019
a 40 search in just a year
and that's expected to keep growing
since the new chinese security law was
enacted last month
a number of countries have pledged to
make it easier for hong kongers to
emigrate
australia taiwan and britain are among
the popular destinations
the uk government will even allow nearly
the 3 million
hong kongers with british national
overseas passports
a document from the colonial era to
settle there
emigration is more than a personal
choice in hong kong it's also a
diplomatic issue
beijing has wanted to stop recognizing
the special british passports of some of
hong kong's residents
in retaliation for britain's offer to
protect them in
some probation heavyweights even
advocate revoking the permanent
residencies of those granted uk
citizenship
which means they could lose the right to
vote and stand for election in hong kong
gary has recently been traveling around
hong kong
to capture its iconic scenery these
pictures
will soon just be memories of the place
he will no longer
call home
especially since many friends will soon
drift apart i treasure the remaining
chances to be together
and i hope i can still contribute to my
hometown by other means
in the future
joining me now from hong kong is
pro-democracy activist
and former secretary general of the
political party demo sister
joshua wong joshua welcome what is your
reaction
to the arrest of jimmy lye
with the threat of beijing which is hard
for us to guarantee our personal safety
and with the crackdown and the mass
arrest conduct with the national
security legislation
we just proved that how the children
effect is being used to silence other
voice
what is the message beijing is trying to
deliver
to the pro-democracy movement in hong
kong with such a high profile arrest
we have no intention to have any
collusion with the foreign force
we have never caught on extension
since drivers after national security
law is implemented
but now beijing just provided misleading
propaganda
and just try to generate more and more
excuse to silence our voice
and to crack down on the protest but no
matter what happened
we're just urging beijing to hold the
accountability
to stop the erosion of universal value
including press freedom and also a free
election that all we fight for
but joshua how successful are you all
being really in your attempts i mean you
as a candidate have been barred from
standing in these elections which
themselves have now been postponed
is it having any impact on beijing
beijing could not censor us out from the
democracy movement they can kick us out
from the office
they can censor us out from balance but
they can't disqualify
our commitment to fight for freedom and
continue to engage in the democracy
movement
you are committed to engaging with the
democracy movement but speaking about
the democratic processes in hong kong
they have been postponed at least for a
year when it comes to the legislative
council
elections the government said it was
because of the coronavirus pandemic
do you believe the government
i believe there's no no ground
to expect the election will still
continue instead of saying they
try to postpone the election now is they
hope they
try to cancel the whole election at all
but do you do you believe their
reasoning that it's because of the
coronavirus pandemic and therefore it
was unsafe
to hold these elections
uh with the threat and the risks
generated by the authorities which is
hard for us to
ensure everything but i think now is the
time for the
world to put hong kong under the global
spotlight
but hong kong in a way is being put
under the global spotlight i mean you
have sanctions that have been imposed
from the united states against carrie
lam for instance and some other
officials
do you think that support is working for
the pro-democracy movement in hong kong
uh we are not only focusing on the move
or the announcement from the united
states i think how country
uh in europe react on the crackdown in
hong kong
would be also remarkable for us to
realize that
it's time to hold the aging
accountability
do you think europe is doing enough to
hold beijing accountable
a different country might have different
foreign policy towards hong kong and
china but no matter
what their original approach and was the
consideration
it's time to reassess house their policy
to continue
enhance uh our fights
and also how they uh really assess their
foreign policy
to the hotline crackdown from beijing
i'd like to talk about you i mean you uh
disbanded your political party
democristo around the time that the new
security law
was being implemented you said you
feared being targeted
by beijing as a result of the new
security law do you still
have those fears
um which is hard for us to ensure
um our safety and i'm not sure when i
will be
arrested and being extradited to china
and we might be all worried about
the threats that we need to face in the
upcoming future but no matter what
happen
we still have no regret at all to
continue
course on free election some of your
colleagues for example
nathan law and others have left hong
kong
to try and bring hong kong's voice to
the
international arena do you plan on
leaving hong kong joshua
will continue to plan to fight for
freedom and that's my decision
joshua wong pro democracy activist
speaking to us from hong kong thank you
very much for your time
you